so discrimination and bias and
inequities is one of the most important
topics of the day today one of the
reasons why is that many many companies
are becoming increasingly diverse
companies value diversity they think
it's really important and yet the way
our brain works we still engage in many
different kinds of biases and they
happen outside of our awareness and so
the more and more that we hear about
this the more and more we talk about it
and have conversations about it the more
it helps us to become just much more
powerful and informed leaders both in
the national context and also in the
international context as well there are
lots of things that we now know about
discrimination that we didn't know
before and oftentimes the science is a
lot more far ahead than what people
think and so for example many people
many many people continue to think that
discrimination is overt it's intentional
it's the bad apples or bad people
engaging in bad behaviors and what we
now know is that most discrimination is
actually quite unintentional it's
unconscious and it happens outside of
our awareness and so a great example of
this is letters of recommendation so
this is a great example because you're
really trying to write a lot of a
recommendation for someone but we know
that their one their winds up being very
very strong gender bias ease when you
write a letter for a woman versus a
letter for a man so letters for men are
longer they use the word brilliant they
use the word genius and they focus on
the person's qualities letters of
recommendation for women tend to be
shorter they use the word team player
and they oftentimes incorporate things
about women's personal lives and so even
when you're really trying hard to
advocate for someone these unconscious
biases can affect how you're actually
advocating for someone when you're
actually on their team and advocating on
their behalf
so that's an example of unintentional
bias it's very much the case that bias
also varies by
group and what I mean by that for
instance is that discrimination and bias
against lesbians gay individuals
transgender individuals bisexuals is on
the decline it's not completely gone but
it's certainly on the decline
however bias against older employees and
this just means people that are over
fifty years old
bias against people who are overweight
and bias against people who have
physical limitations has very much not
changed over the past say 15 years and
in some respects with the inclusion of
technology companies it's actually on
the rise and so we need to be careful to
think that just because discrimination
or bias is declining for some groups
that doesn't decline for all groups at
the same time